what was your biggest failure and how
did I change you to really think hard
about that failure it's how you live
your life in all the little decisions
that you run constantly you are
constantly accepting other people's
limitations and so many people are
afraid of rejection of failure but
without failure you have no success
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message survive failures over
to you Elon Musk
what was your biggest failure and how
did I change you have to really think
hard about that failure there's your
answer well there's a ton of failures
along the way that's for sure
like I said as a support for SpaceX the
first three launches failed and we were
just barely able to scrape together
enough parts and money to do the fourth
launch that fourth launch should fail
who would have been dead so multiple
failures along the way I tried very hard
to get the right expertise in for for
SpaceX I tried hard to to find a great
chief engineer for the rocket but it
that the good chief engineers wouldn't
join and the bad ones well there's no
point in hiring him so I ended up being
chief engineer of the rocket so if I
could have found somebody better then we
would have maybe had less than three
failures so I know we titled this video
survive failure but as I watch it back
the main message I get out of this is
you need to will things into existence
at the beginning of any project you want
to build a team you want to get the best
people on board you want to you want to
not have to do this by yourself but if
nobody's willing to join you then
sometimes you have to you have to will
things into existence sometimes you need
to be an army of one so he didn't want
to be the chief engineer and it led to
three rocket failures that might have
been avoided if you had somebody better
but he still did it and it ended up
working and if you just sat and waited
and waited and waited and waited for the
right person maybe that person never
comes along maybe the company never
takes off and so you need to build
momentum you need to have the mindset I
will will this into existence I don't
want to do everything by myself I want
to build a team I want to go as fast as
possible with as many people on my team
as possible help me build this thing but
if nobody does and that will happen in
early days if nobody does then you will
be an army of one and will this thing
into existence and here's the kicker
here's how I want you to apply it
practically to your life because it's
not just about the big
things it's not just about that make it
break huge decisions for your company
like building a spaceship or not it's
about the day-to-day it's how you live
your life in all the little decisions
that you run constantly you are
constantly accepting other people's
limitations when they say they can't do
it when they say that it's not possible
when they say it'll never happen on
small things you accept their
limitations and that's a mindset shift
by accepting those limitations how do
you think you can go off and build some
big huge impossible thing if you're
accepting these little tiny limitations
so let me give you two quick examples
from TDS trying to dance also I decided
to order a little library and a little
libraries this little library that you
have that people can leave a book and
take a book and it's like a library
within a company or you could put it on
your lawn as well and they came in and I
wanted to get it set up that day and
some of the people that said we can't
build it in one day we don't have the
paint we don't have the stain like all
these reasons why it won't work out like
okay great I'll do it myself this is
happening today this thing will be
finished today and so I started building
it myself and then one other guy joined
me we're painting it together we put it
all together then I went to a different
store and I got the stained and we put
it together and by the end of the day
boom we had a finished little library
another quick example we were working on
a new font for TDs and it was with a
friend and we're looking at different
options and we wanted to see what a font
looked like from uppercase all caps to
lowercase in the the team we're working
well you know we can't do that
we'll get back to you it's like no this
is what's the name with that font and I
pull up my laptop it's like give me the
name of the fun and I'll do it right and
they ended up doing it on the spot so we
can see what it looks like like do not
accept other people's limitations on
what is possible and those seem like
really micro insignificant things and in
truth they are but it's much more about
how you see the world how much you're
willing to hear somebody's opinion and
accept that as fact as opposed to saying
I do not accept the way that you think I
do not accept your limitations and I'm
gonna go off and do it myself and it may
not be perfect and it may be not as good
as you can do it but me doing a job 80%
of the way is better than you doing zero
and so taking that mindset for every
decision you want to have happen no
matter how insignificant that you want
to build a team that you want to
surround yourself with people who
believe in the mission and want to throw
their hearts and souls into it but if
you can't do it from the beginning if
you cannot get somebody to join your
cause then you will be an army of one
you will will it into existence you will
make it happen even if the quality isn't
where you need to be yet because lack of
momentum is not an option and I've got a
really special bonus clip I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know what is a project
that you've been holding off on because
you're waiting for somebody else because
you're waiting for the expertise you're
waiting for their feedback you waiting
for them to do something and what can
you do to just will it into existence
that this thing now has to happen what
does that project leaving the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself
any whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
man so many people are afraid of
rejection of failure but without failure
you'd have no success what was the one
that stung the most as far as failures
we're stuck in the most biggest failure
I had a TV show called the big house got
picked up by ABC they told me that we
were gonna do 12 episodes flew me down
to New York this is the biggest news
ever I'm about to be rich holy I'm 22 I
got a TV show I'm writing executive
producing starring in the show you know
what no I'm not just gonna go down there
by myself we got to bring the cash they
said no Kevin we only flying you I said
well I'm a pay for the cast to come I
took my own money through them all down
in New York get to New York put on my
suit people taking pictures of me
walking out this is the best thing ever
holy I'm famous this is what it is I get
to the up front up front to where they
turn out your TV show the slew of shows
there now Senor time slots I'm next
they're bothered announce the big house
somebody puts their hand on my chest and
says Kevin wait they talking to earpiece
they said nope
I'm standing with him right now I'm like
what's going on what they want me to do
you know they want me go on the other
side or something he goes okay I'll tell
him they cancel they're not gonna pick
you up you got to step back and I was
like that don't sound right literally
that fast they sent me home they're like
you gotta just go home TV show got
picked up six months later for six
episodes the third episodes air they
cancel show again I got the show can't
do twice in a six-month period which has
never been done before I've booked about
three more pilots got canceled there was
a show called John Stamos his show he
was a publicist and they wanted me as a
series regular the show was going great
ratings were good put me on the show
show got canceled it was everything got
touched on TV turned I'm now just
sitting out here doing nothing
I handle money borrow money left and
right I decided safe I said I'm just
gonna do stand-up comedy and focus on my
craft and I slaved the role about five
years doing the same circuit over and
over you're probably gonna fail yeah the
stuff you do is probably gonna suck
you're probably gonna get in trouble
yeah probably not gonna work are you
okay with that if you're not okay with
that
well then that's why you're
having trouble getting your ideas out
there that's why you're having trouble
integrating other people into the team
that's why you're having trouble doing X
Y & Z because you aren't okay with it
not working so you're waiting for the
thing that's sure to work but the thing
that's sure to work isn't gonna happen
yeah and if it is someone's gonna do it
instead of you so all that's left are
the things that are probably not gonna
work yeah the thing is when you were
four you told the joke that was funny
and when you were eight you did a
drawing that was interesting yeah when
you were 14 you had a conversation with
someone that was truly you mean you're
capable of it that's not the question
everyone who's watching this has written
one intelligent sentence I've just
written more than one but it's a matter
of quantity not ability yeah so where
does the quantity come from the quantity
comes from being willing to be wrong
being willing to be made fun of being
willing to be embarrassed being willing
to fail it never gets easier it never
gets fun ever okay fine and gravity also
sucks if we didn't have gravity we could
fly yeah so there's gravity but we don't
whine about gravity we just acknowledge
that there's gravity and we walk anyway
yeah well I think the same thing is true
about the art that we make the
difference that we make that a customer
comes in every day and the fifth day
they come in that looks like they've
been crying it is not your job to say to
them is everything okay and give them a
hug but if you did that what would
happen right it might not work
they might get really angry with you
none of your business but it also might
change their life you could sign up for
that or not and that's what freedom
looks like and that's why freedom is so
scary because freedom doesn't come with
a dummies book and freedom doesn't come
with a permit and freedom doesn't come
with an excuse you have to own it and it
probably isn't gonna work you know I've
written 7,000 blog posts and half of
them were below average I just didn't
know which ones were below average until
after I wrote altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video